so i get my question for you is you're
one of the few who decides to retire and
you're
crushing the game you're vip the huge
organization
and then what like and i'm saying this
because i like you i care about you it's
like
when you i heard you're coming back i'm
like why man oh i
i think a lot of people had that
reaction but some people were really
excited like myself i'm obviously
excited yeah i'm not saying i'm not
excited
no i can't choose why um
if there's no better answer than i just
want to like that's it that's really
works for me
i just want to know where i just feel
like i can do it
and i i made sure to
go through it you know kind of that
checklist of things before
i decided to like make that official and
announce what's the checklist so
basically
you know i have had two kids and i
wanted to make sure my body could still
do it that the sport hadn't passed me by
that i could get in that kind of shape
that i could avoid the injury and that i
could still like
fight or flight you know they talk about
that being an instinct i mean i think
once
a fighter always a fighter but it's one
thing to think that and it's one thing
to go in there and prove it you know
especially after two kids
exactly and and you know for over four
years of being retired you know i
haven't done a ton of sparring in those
four years but
i also think that's going to lead to my
longevity now
you know that i'm a little bit later in
my career i'm smarter i feel like my
body is finally connecting with my
my mindset i'm just more mature i look
at things in a different way
and um i just i so anyways the checklist
was
making sure that i could that all those
things basically sport hadn't passed me
by could i still do it could i hang
could i get on that level could i get
back into that kind of shape
was there a fight you were watching or
i'm sure you watch ufc so you watch
something like i can hear those girls
yeah certain guys yeah yeah that no that
never goes away that's right no i don't
think
i don't want to yeah but in my head i'm
like i could beat that guy
yeah did you still have fights left oh
yeah if i came back they i think i have
four fights left on my contract
got it okay so was there a fight you
were watching like i could beat her
no it just sorry i've always felt that
way yeah but with like most
you know most all of them like i always
just feel that way but
i don't know that's part of being a
fighter i think right you got to kind of
feel that was it
yeah like i think you always got to feel
that way you know know that you can
but again i had to prove that to myself
so
i went back to the gym and i started
training so it's right around the time
that i had my son so that would be about
almost 10 months ago now that's when i
had the force slow down and it was just
kind of like
everything hit a halt i knew i was done
having kids
and i was like 34. i was like now
i think time started to become relevant
i was like i think we want to make
another run at this
and did you tell your man and your
family were they like come on so i told
my
obviously i told my man first i told
johnny i said uh
um scooter's coming up to say hi so you
got food for me
um so i told him first and i just wanted
to see what he would think because
obviously you know with the kids it's a
different
ball game like we had oh yeah i mean we
have so much
it's very overwhelming at times i'm not
going to lie about it i like my mom with
you i got two toddlers and you know this
weekend it is so hard i'm home i'm not
on tour and you know it's
grandma grandpa's not around just me and
my girl and we're like man what are we
gonna do i know if the struggle is real
two days it is just us it's like we
gotta figure out what to do like you're
in it
absolutely so then i don't and i'm not
familiar with are you married or
just no we're not married yeah so yeah
get there someday so is he
is he a fighter is in your fight game
fighter so he's fought on the ultimate
fighter before
um and now he fights for one
championship okay so he understands it
yeah yeah he understands it definitely
so
yeah he gets it he knows what's gonna
have to go into it and of course very
supportive but
he's always my rock because i'm kind of
just like
i don't know like sometimes i get these
ideas and i just
and i just i just go like i've never
been very like i have to be
you know follow this path yeah that kind
of thing it says it invades me i'm just
like fly by the seat of my pants
now i have way more structure in my life
because i have kids but i'm still that
way in my heart
if i feel something if i feel passionate
about it like i'm going to go with it
yeah and that's why and i'm all in
that's and that's why the comeback was a
lot more
well thought out yes exactly you know
because it's like i knew in my heart
what i wanted to do but i'm also like
you know how my man's like you know well
we got to do these things to make sure
like before you before you go and say
something and i didn't want to
put any pressure on myself i just want
to enjoy it i want to come back and see
like what i could do what kind of shape
i could get in and like to be honest
like
if i went in there if i got injured if i
couldn't hang if i couldn't physically
hack it then
you know i would have known and i would
have never said anything to anybody but
i'm sure you're doing pretty well in
training
right yeah you're a little beast yeah so
so then uh when you told one
championship we're like oh come on
because they know you're probably not
gonna be able to i don't know if that's
the way
yeah i don't know if that's the way that
they felt but they but that's not what
they said like when i talked to cha tree
who is the ceo and founder of one
championship he was he was 100
supportive like it's not it's not very
often you find a friend in the business
world that
has you know that your dreams are going
to kind of
counter in in a way what would be
beneficial to them but they're still
going to support you in that
mission you know again my point with one
championship like you said
they're supportive of it is like what's
good for you is good for them like the
bigger misha tate gets
right associated one championship in the
vps yeah for them
exactly but i had to put in my 30 days
so
ufc right yeah so i've got like maybe
two weeks left
and then then you can always go back i'm
sure like the doors open
i think so i mean we left on amicable
terms they've been really good to me i
had a good experience there
like i have no no you know
i mean i don't know which direction i'm
not you know i'm not promising anything
i don't know if i'll continue to work
with ufc after i'm done fighting or if
i'll go back to one championship but i
think doors are open either way
which is it's just nice to have options
and then uh
is there any opponents in mind or
because
did i read that your your first lights
can be at 45
so is that the plan no so it originally
i thought about it
because like i'm still breastfeeding my
son and everything like that and i was
like i don't have to diet and cut weight
and like worry about
you know milk supply and all that stuff
but um
i wanted options when i started to look
at the 145 pound division
it's like they let they just let megan
anderson go now there's two women
and amanda's coming back down to 135.
that division i mean there's nothing
there
you know what i mean so it's like
felicia spencer and danielle wolf
are fighting but daniel wolf was like i
don't know she's like one or two fights
in mma
not very much i think she's like 101 or
want to know or something
and then there's felicia which i think
would be a great fight i would love to
maybe fight her someday but yeah
i mean if we're not going to have a
division with fights to keep me busy no
longevity there
so you beat felicia what are you gonna
do that's what i guess they maybe amanda
nunes if she wants to do it
yeah but you know to be honest i've been
out for four and a half years like
i don't think amanda for my second fight
would be a very smart decision
you know what i mean she's a total
badass and it's great i want to fight
her again but
i want to make sure i do things the
right way and give myself the best
opportunity to win and i don't think
jumping in off
one fight is the best thing to do but
you're such a big name too so it puts
ufc in a tough spot because it's not
like they can just toss you some newbie
you know like calling home was like i'm
down for that like all these
dogs because you're a big dog in this
case you're you know
you know the mountain rush more female
fighting so all of them want their shot
at michael tate now i know it's funny
actually i've been hearing a lot of but
i mean that's great i'll be the second
most hunted woman in the division
you know there'll be amanda and it'll be
me yep and she doesn't do tune-up fights
though like
like boxing you come out for your life
no there's no tune-up they don't they
don't play
it's very it's sink or swim very
she's one of the most famous female
fighters of all time so they're not
gonna
damn they're not gonna give it right
like you know what i mean
i'm not making a comparison to miesha
but you look at like even with cm punk
like have fun dude and he just yeah
never fought before she got absolutely
destroyed
yeah can we get him a newer guy
he'll figure it out and they're like and
if he doesn't he doesn't yeah
i mean they don't want to build up
records and have people be i didn't know
that
34 years old two kids in four year
layoffs and you go in there with the
shorts
yeah basically and you ready yeah
absolutely i mean that's i gotta be
that's fine yeah yeah but so my
so the first woman that i'm that i'm
scheduled to fight is maureen renau are
you familiar with her yes
yeah okay no it's not an easy fight
bring her up chin no it's not easy it's
not
she she so this is what this is what
is um what is
right she's at belizean she's 43.
but she's coming off losses correct she
is so that's the worst part about this
is she's a lot better
than what her record says in my opinion
so she has four losses but they're all
wait no close decisions she's never been
finished
she's lost split decision she's been on
the verge of being a contender a number
of times
she's finished jessica andraj which is
like impossible to do
she triangle choked her then she hurt uh
sarah mcmahon on the feet and triangle
choked sarah mcmahon
that's not easy to triangle choke you
know what i mean it's like so she's got
these
wins that's a weird fight huh because
it's yeah i guess people like oh she's
coming out four losses good good
it's like kind of like easy it's not
office it's a
it's a lot like it's kind of like
worries me because i'm like people
really look at that and they're just
going to see a record like oh four
lessons i'm like i don't look at that
at all that way those losses were all
decision losses and they were pretty
close like
she held her own like she never was in
major trouble she's never been in major
trouble
she's never been finished she's never
been like knocked down like she's never
she's tough she's durable she can do
everything she's a black belt in jiu
jitsu she can strike
you know she can re she can clinch
wrestle um
and when when's that fight so let's go
down yeah july 17th
oh that's wrong yeah you got time yeah i
mean
i got time because i've been doing this
um i've been training for you know
months now so
and then did your manager call the ufc
say come back or did you handle that
no i did i actually was like bugging
dana on instagram and i have no idea why
but he blew off like my first five dms
about wanting to come back just didn't
see him
no he saw them that's why i met him he
didn't respond
that's why i messaged him on instagram
because i'm like i'll be able to see if
he read it you know like i wanted to
know
like i wasn't gonna send like a text
message like i wanna know he saw that
[ __ ]
yeah were you nervous when you uh dm'd
him
kinda but then i saw and then i got i
started to be like maybe someone else is
running his account
you know you never know like maybe
someone else thought he's in it on
social media
but i was like maybe i don't know maybe
there's a person that's checking it or
you know helps him out with some things
and they opened it and he didn't
actually see i was trying to make up
excuses but deep down i really knew he
just was like
ignoring me he probably was like oh
she's not serious that's what i wanted
that's what i think
she's fine in one championship and then
what what got over the hump where he
started engaging with you
so through dm or text no it's all
through
instagram so i wrote this long message
and i was like look i'm not gonna come
back to the us and move my family back
and you know
you know leave one championship is what
i really look like i probably would have
to do right that's what i was
assuming would happen i'm not going to
do that jump from one tree until i have
another
to make sure so where you know where are
we at with this i want to fight and then
he just said come home
that's all he said in just two weeks oh
damn that's pretty gay
but i know right but i kind of took that
as like put your money where your mouth
is
like if you're really serious about
wanting to fight and prove yourself
it makes sense yeah i'm sure he's blown
up all the time
yeah it's all right move home let's see
what happens yeah so i did
you know yeah i'm here dude exactly all
right we'll get you [ __ ] up then i
came into the office and he's like so
what are you doing here i was like
what do you mean he's like what do you
want i was like i want to [ __ ] fight
yeah
like that's what i want to do i came
home i know right here i am
and he just still was kind of like okay
like he was still kind of like
you know why he's like are you not
making good money i think that was the
other thing maybe he was concerned about
me being desperate
right that it washed up misha tate was
gonna come back and desperate to feed
her family kind of thing and just
get my ass kicked and take a paycheck
and leave you know
um but i was like no i really want to
fight i was like okay well wait what i
was like probably 45 so i don't have to
worry about cutting weight or just walk
in fat and happy
and he was like okay um
what did he say he said well oh he said
45 is a rematch with amanda and i said
so is 35.
like either way i'm gonna get to it you
know what i mean so
i just uh i was like that's fine with me
that's what i want anyways at the end of
the day like i want to fight her again i
want to
i want to do it i want to be the baddest
woman on the planet again and then
the since you left you know especially
four years ago that 35 is stacked
it's a bit of a difference it is well it
is but a lot of the women that
when i left are still on the top so
that's why another reason why i
definitely don't feel like
you know the sports like quote unquote
passed me by i mean holly you've seen
her get a you know
numerous title shots again she's still
talking about wanting to make another
run at it
i mean juliana pena we grew up in this
sport together she's gonna fight
you know for the title next like a lot
of the women marion renault right this
is her retirement fight
granted but i mean she's been in the ufc
close to as long as i have um
i would say cats and gano obviously she
went over to bellator but she's still in
it she's still winning fights right
these are women that uh cyborg amanda
amanda too you know to be honest
yeah i mean yeah she so come back like
crazy yeah but
those are all women that were in my in a
better in my hair
you know she's been around forever holly
holm doing this sarah mcmahon
pena mcmahon yeah
yeah they're all doing it so you know
it's a it's a good mixture but a lot of
them are still from my what i would
consider my generation of fighting and
they're still doing
great things and still holding top five
spots and top 10 spots mostly all of
them actually
um so yeah i definitely think like i
still have time and
was there any uh idea or was there any
attempt to get released from the ufc
contract so you can find one
championship just make it easy
well i think this is a route right yeah
that would have been the easiest route
but i knew that they weren't going to do
that just based on we tried to do a
grappling match with one championship
and they ex-nade that real quick dana
didn't like that you're too you're
too big of a name yeah so i guess i mean
that's what it is
and to be fair like the uf the ufc had
so much to do with
elevating my brand correct you know i
think people cared a little bit coming
from strikeforce you know ron and i had
that great
fight it's one and and you know gina and
cyborg
since that time kind of moved forward
and it was a big part of that movement i
think people started to care about it
but
it was still a lot of hardcore fans you
know hardcore fans really cared it
wasn't so much
like it is now mainstream yeah when i
think of uh women's fighting you talk
about the pioneers it's like gina
cyborg rhonda and you and then amanda
you know came on late and obviously
she's the dominant face of the
woman's fighting all women's fighting so
there's like you five are in mount
rushmore
yeah and you know amanda i don't think
she was too much behind us though you
know she's i think she's 32
but she just didn't get noticed until
she
changed camps and then changed camp than
the maturity right like
you look at that fight with cats and
ghana right she had she's beating
[ __ ] out of cat and just kind of you
know got tired and then got beat
and i think she learned from that now
she's just this absolute
dominant champ man yeah dominant yeah i
think that's good for you and your
advantages
you know her before that these girls
find her now like megan and
stuff like that you know they see her as
this the goat the lion
you don't see that no i'm just like no
that's i've i've
i've seen him i've seen her exactly and
i've seen her losing an
invicta oh sarah delelio i'm pretty sure
it was saturday leo peter but uh
um yeah i've seen her lose before i mean
i know she has her weaknesses and stuff
i think is such a big advantage because
a lot of those girls like you know i
love megan and so
i think she was beat before it even
started i agree completely agree
she looked like her eyes got like this
big as soon as the bell went and amanda
started marching across the way and she
was just kind of like ah and i was like
well i will not
be like ah when i fight her i promise
you that like you know
i can't i can't promise victory you guys
but i can always promise that i'll bring
a hell of a fight and i'm not scared of
any woman on this planet
is there besides her is there any other
fights redemption fights or anything
like that you're looking for
um i wish i could run it back again with
kat but
she's over in bellator right now so
that's kind of just a great fight
yeah i would really like to to run it
back with that
um you know and then i i think i'll end
up fighting holly again it's not really
something i'm like gunning down because
i i beat holly so it's not like you know
uh you know like gotta have it but i'm
sure she'll be one of those six fights
though yeah
i'm sure she will be at some point i'd
love to fight jermaine that's one that
i've never
i never got the opportunity to fight her
so i'm pretty sure you're gonna you're
gonna win this one then
you're looking at those those top top
women exactly you're looking at you know
top three and i think jermaine is yeah
she's one she's one holly holm's two
i'm interested in jana too cause i think
yana and jermaine
those would be fun fights for me those
women are both
you know ranked really high and and um
you know yana she's improving every
fight that i see her she's getting
better yeah she's getting a lot better
she's got good striking
she you know she's fought cyborg so i
know she's not scared you know she's not
scared to fight people
and she comes to fight she gets better
with her wrestling been seeing her take
people down and
you know land her ground and pound and
stuff so i think that'd be a good one
too how about that
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
on i'm just saying dude grab that mic
son